i just always looked at you from afar
and said
this guy is always going to be a
bachelor there's no way it's not that
he's not a loving man it's not that he
can you know but it's just his life is
so busy and he had said he would never
get married
what is the love story there it's a
great story actually i was in
uh lake como single and a friend of mine
said this is okay if i bring my friend
over i'm on my way to the cannes film
festival can i bring my
friend over and my mom and dad were
staying with me in como at the time
and a couple of other friends and i was
like sure
bring her over and in walks them all
and she's you know stunning and funny
and the smartest person in every room
she walks into
and uh and i was really taken with her
we didn't
you know we we set up all night and
talked but we didn't date we
we just started uh we started writing
each other
and uh i would i wrote her for i don't
know a few months
and then i came to um uh london
you mean there's nothing sexual between
the two of you you just
platonic friends but it's obvious
there's some kind of chemistry there
well i liked her but i couldn't i didn't
want to you know jump the shark on it i
couldn't tell if
she liked me because you know i'm 17
years older than her so she might have
thought i was you know
grandpa right yeah yeah and then when i
got to
london to score a movie we were scoring
at abbey road and i thought well
if you're ever going to impress anybody
it's with 150 piece orchestra
at abbey road and you know so in other
words in your mind you're like i know
what i'm going to do with this one
i'm going to we got to move this thing
yeah i'm providing a rover to abbey road
i'll sit there and like just the ho hum
it's another day at work
and she just come from a meeting where
she was trying to tamp down a problem
with the muslim brotherhood
she comes to abbey road oh boy what is
going on george i mean let's get to the
romance so so she's got to be
impressed when she walked into the abbey
road i don't know if she would
compared to all the other things that uh
she was um uh
dealing with that day i think you know
abby wrote might have just been a relief
um then it was tricky because you're in
london which is a city with a lot of
paparazzi following you and so
you know we we went out to dinner
quietly no one saw us
and we went out to dinner and then you
know it became romantic very quickly
and then it was kind of clear once we
knew that
we both you know she i knew that she was
interested
then i think we were together from that
moment on and i mean
it was really interesting because we had
to hide for
i don't know a couple of months because
you just want to make sure
you know you don't want you want to get
to know each other and get to spend time
with each other and not do it
you know on the front page of hello
magazine and the funniest part was that
she
gets a letter from her father going i'm
going to give you 10 reasons why this is
a terrible idea
[Laughter]
which there are wedding vows basically